[Musique]
monsieur le préfet de police je commence
chacune de ses auditions en rappelant
qu'un faux témoignage devant notre
commission des lois doté des
prérogatives d'une commission denquête
serait passible de cinq ans
d'emprisonnement et de 75000 euros
damende je vous invite à prêter serment
de dire toute la vérité rien que la
vérité levé la main droite et dit je le
jure je le jure monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le préfet vous avez la parole
pour une introduction de cette audition
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les membres de la commission des lois
je veux d'abord comme le doit tout
représentant de l'état sur le territoire
tout préfet salué les représentants de
la nation que vous êtes parlementaires
élus de la république et leur exprimer
les salutations à la fois respectueuse
et cordiale qui vous sont dues le
courrier que vous m'avez adressées m'a
exposé à la fois le cadre juridique dans
lequel intervient moan audition en
indiquant que votre commission disposer
des prérogatives attribuées aux
commission denquête afin de mener sa
mission d'information sur les conditions
dans lesquelles des personnes
n'appartenant pas aux forces de sécurité
intérieure ont pu ou peuvent être
associés à l'exercice de leurs missions
de maintien de l'ordre et de protection
des hautes personnalités de régime des
sanctions applicables en cas de
manquement accompagné de mon
collaborateur au cabinet commissaire
principal mariole le directeur adjoint
des ressources humaines de la préfecture
de police d'inspecteur général jérôme
foucault je vais m'efforcer monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs te répondre à votre attente en
faisant un cadrage mais je vais essayer
d'être très rapides sûres
les modalités générales de l'accueil
d'observateurs à la préfecture de police
et en venant vite à l'épisode du 1er mai
qui a justifié l'initiative que vous
avez pris les observateurs accueillis à
la préfecture de police
je veux dire en quelques mots que nous
sommes très régulièrement sollicités
pour recevoir au sein de nos directions
des personnes extérieures à leur
institution et à ses demandes qui
correspondent à des objectifs de
formation d'informations de
connaissances répond la volonté de
transparence et de renforcement du lien
police population que poursuivre nos
services et j'y suis attaché c'est dire
que par principe la préfecture de police
accueil ses demandes et c'est de tout
faire pour les honorer et le refus reste
très exceptionnel nous sommes dans cette
logique d'ouverture
quels sont les publics concernés en
quelques mots le type de présence et je
me permettrai quelques réflexions sur le
cadre juridique les publics concernés il
ya d'abord une grande catégorie qui
touche aux besoins de formation
les publics scolaires et étudiants ces
700 collégiens lycéens et étudiants
accueillis depuis le début de l'année
c'est les besoins de formation d'autres
institutions les auditeurs de justice
les stagiaires de l'institut des
national des hautes études de sécurité
et de justice
des policiers auditeurs étrangers des
cadres sud de santé dont les médecins
urgentistes des policiers municipaux
d'élèves de grandes écoles polytechnique
lira des fonctionnaires de l'éducation
nationale
à l'heure actuelle à titre d'exemple sun
la drpj nous avons des auditeurs de
justice de l'école nationale de la
magistrature
je signale également une particularité
qui est la cellule synapses de la
direction de l'ordre public et de la
circulation j'en parle puisque nous
allons parler tout à l'heure de la des
opc c'est une cellule de réflexion et de
prospective sur le thème du maintien
d'ordre du maintien de l'ordre public
qui essaie de voir à la fois à travers
les retours d'expérience mais également
sur des exemples à l'étranger et les
fonctionnaires s'y déplacent comment
évoluent les techniques comment les
faire évoluer le cadre juridique le gade
technologique nous avons un partenariat
avec sciences po sciences po paris pour
des étudiants du master politiques
publiques spécialité sécurité et défense
qui sont associés à raison de trois par
semaine à ce travail à la fois c'est un
travail si vous permettez l'expression
d'état major mais également ses
étudiants sont peuvent être sur le
terrain ça c'est le besoin de formation
le besoin d'information c'est la
question des médias des journalistes à
mon cabinet un service de communication
qui est important qui est bien structuré
qui est dirigée par une commissaire
divisionnaire de la police nationale les
journalistes sont souvent demandeurs de
reportages d'immersion au sein d'unités
tels que la berri la bac de nuit où ils
espèrent trouver des images un peu
accrocheuse pour leur public depuis le
début de l'année 2018
ces 63 délégation de presse qui ont été
accueillis dans ce cadre souvent donc de
la presse télévisuelle
ensuite il ya les observateurs que je
vais inscrire dans le cadre général du
partenariat liant police-population
ouverture et transparence là le public
est très diverse et des élus c'est des
fonctionnaires le directeur général de
la police nationale elle nous a
spontanément décrié t tout ceci wagons
par le menu j'accélère les jeux passent
vite j'ajoute aussi ça va de soi mais je
tiens à le souligner les institutions
que nous accueillons et qui de par leur
vocation à venir auprès de nous je pense
en particulier aux délégués du défenseur
des droits qui est veuf qui sont
présents sur certaines opérations une
des dernières grosses opérations à paris
vous les représentants du défenseur des
droits était sur le terrain c'était
l'évacuation du camp des campements dit
du millénaire dans le nord de la
capitale où les défendeurs
présentant le défenseur des droits était
était sur place mais là on a un cadre
juridique évidemment qui est qui est
prévu alors les activités auxquelles ces
personnes assistent ou participent sont
de deux ordres d'une part il ya des
activités finalement assez classique
d'observation de découverte au sein des
locaux policiers je vais passer vite
parce que c'est pas trop votre sujet
ensuite il ya des activités de présence
sur la voie publique pour l'observation
de missions opérationnelles
souvent il s'agit d'accompagner une
patrouille ou unités d'intervention de
police les très souvent les demandes
c'est les patrouilles de type brigade
anti criminalité notamment les brigades
anticriminalité de nuit où ces
observateurs or se trouvaient à bord des
véhicules de de police c'est certaines
unités telles que par exemple la
préfecture de police la la brigade
fluviale c'est aussi des demandes pour
assister un service d'ordre public
je cite là également pour donner du
concret deux présences en cours l'une
qui répond à ma propre demandé à la
demande d'un cabinet dans code
d'accompagnement que j'ai mis en place
pour nous aider dans le
l'appropriation des dispositifs néo ses
nouveaux smartphones qui utilisent les
policiers de terrain pour accéder aux
fichiers et qui est en train de
bouleverser l'activité l'activité locale
et donc j'ai demandé à un cabinet
d'audit de nous de nous aider il a mis
en place ce dispositif à la police
métropolitaine de manchester mais les
membres de ce cabinet d'audit sont
auprès de mes fonctionnaires pour voir
in concreto sur le terrain comment ils
utilisent cet outil par le hasard du
calendrier j'ai reçu hier la demande
d'un chef d'entreprise de 44 ans donc
assez expérimentés qui m'a écrit par
mail en dix ans malgré le contexte je
vous demandais pour assister au service
d'ordre qui sera en place dimanche pour
l'étape d'arrivée du tour de france sur
les champs-elysées on a c'est un
intervenant que nous nous connaissons
déjà j'ai donné mon autorisation et il
se rend place sur le terrain auprès d'un
contrôleur général sur ces observateurs
le cabinet systématiquement sollicité
dans le cadre des demandes des
journalistes
les observateurs sont accueillis par une
autorité est prise en charge par un
policier référent ça peut être de
différents niveaux
lorsqu'il est dans un véhicule d'une bac
c'est le chef de bord qui est son
référent
la présence sur le terrain lorsque le
fonctionnement des services le permet et
si la mission le justifie nous équipons
les personnes d'un gilet pare balles le
cas échéant d'un casque en tout cas qui
va être dans le dans le véhicule pour
assurer leur leur protection
évidemment ils ne sont jamais armée ne
sont pas équipés de radios et encore
moins de brassards de police un mot pour
terminer mon propos sur le cadre
juridique ce qui est très classique et
très très clair c'est les conventions
pour tout ce qui touche les activités de
formation depuis les publics scolaires
jusqu'à tous les partenariats de
formation que j'ai cités en passant par
les stagiaires individuel en 2010 7123
conventions ont été signées dans ce
cadre c'est dire que c'est un volume
important pour les journalistes nous
avons mis également en place pour ses
reportages d'immersion une convention
particulière pour leur rappeler les
droits et les limites de leur action
notamment en songeant vous le savez à
une décision récente de la cour de
cassation qui avait frappé de nullité
une procédure parce que le
l'interpellation à l'intervention elle
était suivie par une équipe de
télévision pour les autres observateurs
ils doivent être autorisées au niveau
pertinent au niveau pertinent ça veut
dire quoi la préfecture de police
c'est plus de 30 mille fonctionnaires et
une autorité qui est une autorité
territoriales déconcentrées le préfet de
police
il va de soi que toutes les décisions ne
viennent pas à mon niveau pour les tout
ce qui est presse est gérée à mon
cabinet et c'est moi qui donne l'accord
en mon absence
le préfet directeur de mon cabinet pour
les conventions de formation ça se gère
au niveau de la direction des ressources
humaines qui al sa tête c'est un
directeur au sens de directeurs
d'administration centrale pour les
autres observateurs c'est évidemment au
cas par cas
je demande toujours que ce soit le
niveau directeur qui soit le niveau qui
valide mais l'initiative peut-être
locale si un élu d'un arrondissement
parisien veut une soirée intervenir ou
plus exactement être présent à côté
d'une bac dans son quartier il va en
parler aux commissaires d'arrondissement
qui a priori donnera son accord en tout
cas c'est la consigne qui l'a de donner
son accord qui renvoie compte à sa
direction qui validera et kim anh
informera cette décision va pas venir
personnellement jusqu'à moi vous vous en
doutez bien comme je lé indiqué ou en
tout cas ça va de soi on est dans
l'observation et on n'est pas dans
l'association aux missions de police et
de ce point de vue
il ya une question que sans doute votre
commission aura à approfondir que sans
aucun doute aussi la mission européenne
dont on vous a parlé
la directrice que lui a confié le
ministre pourra nous éclairer
c'est un questionnement sur la
couverture sur le cadre juridique jeu
difficile me semble-t-il d'associer les
observateurs à des collaborateurs du
service public par principe
ils ne doivent pas participer à cette
action mais on arrive au coeur de
questions c'est à dire que quand nous
disons que le champ de nos
investigations c'est la manière dont des
personnels qui ne sont pas membres de la
police nationale ou de la gendarmerie
peuvent être associés nous voulons dire
peuvent participer ne voulons pas dire
peuvent être associés comme spectateur
alors mais je vais si vous le permettez
moi monsieur le président vous vous
livrez ces deux réflexions je me pose
vraiment la question de la protection
juridique de ces personnes qui sans
doute mériteraient d'être clarifiés
pense que la théorie du collaborateur du
service public mais je peux parler de
bien meilleurs experts que moi et
difficile a sollicité qu'il faudrait
peut-être aller un petit peu plus loin
sachez par exemple que pour les
stagiaires
on vérifie qu'ils ont une attestation
d'assurance qu'il est qu'il est protégé
un petit sujet de de la sorte mais en
tous les cas ce que j'évoque là c'est
être présent à un observateur et en
aucun cas être associé à l'exécution du
même du service public si je reprends
une une catégorie juridique
évidemment non il n'en est pas question
j'ai envie de dire il ne doit pas à
naître question et il faut surtout pas
aller sur ce sur ce terrain jean vient
bien sûr à ce qui s'est passé le 1er mai
dans la dans la capitale sujet sur
lequel j'ai eu déjà l'occasion de
m'exprimer publiquement
je reviens pas sur les circonstances du
1er mai sauf si vous le souhaitez
simplement pour souligner que ça a été
une journée extrêmement difficile et des
phénomènes de violence que l'on n'avait
jamais connu
je redis que c'est le 2 mai dans la
matinée autour de 10h 10h15 que j'ai été
alertée par un appel téléphonique venant
du palais de l'elysée sur ce que mon
interlocuteur désigne affaires benalla
et selon la formule je suis très étonné
je ne comprends pas je lui demande de
quoi il s'agit il n'explique les choses
l'existence de cette vidéo
j'ai joué assez vite le cabinet du
ministre de l'intérieur qui m'a indiqué
être déjà informé être en liaison avec
l'elysée
j'ai demandé évidemment mes
collaborateurs de trouver très vite
cette vidéo nous l'avons regardé
ensemble sur un grand écran dans le
bureau de mon directeur de cabinet jeudi
un grand écran parce que sur un
téléphone portable c'était petit et puis
sur le grand écran peut-être
pourrions-nous reconnaître monsieur
monsieur benalla ce qui n'était pas du
tout évident et ça ça se passe donc le
le 2 mai au matin j'ai eu contact aussi
après avoir prévenu le cabinet du
ministre de nouveau avec le palais de
l'elysée pour expliquer les choses
telles que je les avais vus à l'écran et
il était clair pour moi que le dossier
était pris en compte par ce que
j'appelle l'autorité hiérarchique
monsieur benalla était sous la
responsabilité de l'autorité
hiérarchique du directeur de cabinet de
la présidence et non pas de moi même mes
réactions en interne pour faire vite je
demande immédiatement à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
bref pourquoi et comment il était là
sachant que j'avais été très étonné la
veille au soir de croiser monsieur
benalla dans la salle de commandement où
j'avais accueilli le ministre
mais c'est en faisant le tour vous
n'êtes là étonné moi je fais tu es sur
le terrain voilà la réponse que j'ai eu
et très vite le direct immédiatement le
directeur de l'ordre public et de la
circulation m'a dit je n'étais pas
informé du fait que monsieur benalla
était ce jour là dans nos rangs qui mène
son enquête interne qui fait apparaître
le niveau d'organisation de la venue de
monsieur benalla autorisation réponse à
sollicitations je ne sais pas les
enquêtes en cours au plancher
hier le diront peut-être c'est pourquoi
je dis le niveau d'organisation et
d'accueil au niveau d'un contrôleur
général chef d'état major adjoint qui
s'appelle monsieur simona donc il y a eu
du côté de l'elysée monsieur patrick
strzoda mon collègue ami patrick strzoda
l'a dit l'autorisation donnée par le
cabinet du président de la république à
monsieur benalla devenir le 1er mai sur
le territoire de la préfecture de police
à la préfecture de police a eu lieu au
niveau d'un contrôleur général
l'organisation de sa venue le directeur
adjoint de l'ordre public
le directeur de l'ordre public n'était
pas informé le préfet de police
encore moins voilà exactement comment
les choses se sont se sont passées pour
la connaissance de ceux de ce
déplacement
j'ai dans le menu précisé l'enchaînement
de de ces informations successives
à ce stade je ne peux en dire plus si
vous le permettez je répondrai en
revanche très volontiers à toutes les
questions qui vont suivre j'espère ne
pas avoir été trop longs et ne pas trop
avoir pris l engagement que j'avais pris
de ce point de vue monsieur le président
messieurs le préfet je vous remercie
la question la plus simple qui me vient
à l'esprit est la suivante au fonds
beaucoup d'informations ont été données
sur le moment précis auquel vous même le
directeur de cabinet du ministre le
ministre le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république ont été
informés de la participation de monsieur
benalla à une opération de maintien de
l'ordre pour laquelle il était
naturellement tout à fait illégitime
qu'il apporte un concours
nous comprenons que dès le 2 mai mais
autre autorité que j'ai cités dont vous
faites partie et qui se sont concertés
en tout cas qui ont été qui ont eu des
échanges entre elles prennent la
décision de ne pas saisir l'inspection
générale de la police nationale
et de ne pas faire usage de l'article 40
du code de procédure pénale
je veux savoir si c'est une décision
tacite ou une décision concertée
la réponse monsieur le président relève
de la plus tôt de la catégorie de
décisions tacite il n'y a pas eu en tant
que tel de décision je vous redis de mon
point de vue comment cela a été vécu
encore une fois j'avais été alerté par
le palais de l'elysée qui j'ai fait
remonter parce que je ne pouvais
analyser et c'est donc là la surprise la
condamnation est immédiatement le palais
dialyse et m'a dit que c'était lui qui
prenait en compte si vous voulez comme
autorités responsables hiérarchiques et
pour moi il était clair que c'était à ce
niveau que ça devait se dérouler
quand l'appréciation des suites à donner
selon la formule c'est l'autorité
compétente et donc c'est ce qui m'a
guidée de manière assez simple et assez
évidente je dois le dire donc y at il eu
concertation
y at il eu ordre de ne pas utiliser la
tk rente et c'est sûrement pas sûrement
pas c'est vous pouvez l'appeler décision
tacite mais il n'y a eu aucun échange
sur le thème faut-il faut-il pas qui non
non et non c'est donc du tacite au terme
des échanges comme vous l'indiquez voilà
comment ça s'est passé
sur le fond le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république s'est exprimé
hier vous avez eu également le l'analyse
que l'igpn a fait de ce sujet
puisqu'elle avait reçu la vidéo
mais j'ajoute que pour le préfet de
police la petite nuance supplémentaires
c'est que le le débordement la faute
le manquement le dérapage personnel il
n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire de
police
il n'est pas le fait d'un fonctionnaire
de police
il est le fait d'un collaborateur du de
la présidence de la république et non
pas d'un personnel placé sous mon
autorité et ses 2
le point qui pour moi était cardinal
dans le si vous voulez la position qui a
été qui a été la mienne parce que moi si
je vois la vidéo je vois pas la vidéo
contrairement à le croire nos amis de
l'igpn qui ne savaient pas qu'ils
étaient les personnes
moi quand je vois la vidéo c'est pour
que je puisse confirmer oui c'est bien
monsieur b dallas que j'aurais été
incapable de reconnaître il a fallu
vraiment qu'on voit sur un grand écran
et on était plusieurs autour de moi pour
pour l'identifier mais c'est pas moi qui
les identifiait premier puisqu'on m'a
alertée encore une fois je crois que
tout le monde l'a bien comprise et
partant de là le manquement la faute et
qui sera devant a examinées par les
tribunaux de l'ordre judiciaire c'est
pas un fonctionnaire de police
c'est pas vous faire de police et l'igpn
est compétente et je saisi l'igpn pour
les gens qui sont sous mon autorité
meilleur exemple le 19 juillet je viens
la journée du 19 juillet pour vous
donner l'exemple
je rappelle que la veille au soir nous
avons été un certain nombre à être
alertés sur le fait que le journal le
monde allait comme on dit entre nous
sortir la vidéo benalla on va prendre
cette expression familière que tout le
monde comprend je n'ai alerté le
directeur donc public j'ai refait le
point avec lui un de ses collaborateurs
le lendemain matin pour bien se remettre
en tête les faits et du 1er mai place de
la contrescarpe parce que le 1er mai
pour le préfet de police
ça n'a pas été que la place de la
contrescarpe je me permets de le je me
permets de le rappeler et
le lendemain je vous le rappelle enfin
en tout cas je l'indiquent devant votre
commission
il était un peu avant 14 heures lorsque
monsieur alain gibelin directeur de
l'ordre public demande à me voir sans
délai j'avais un déjeuner de travail
avec un collègue mais j'ai dit venez
donc à la résidence j'ai quitté
d'ailleurs la table du déjeuner et là il
me révèle avec stupeur et un peu
effondré voilà on le commissaire kroes a
vient de me révéler ce qu'ils ont fait
hier soir avec deux autres collègues
c'est à dire récupérer une des images un
support qui avait été pris de la scène
de la contrescarpe pour aller la porter
à monsieur benalla ma réaction est ce
assez pour répondre à la question
l'ag des fonctionnaires qui sont sous
mon autorité sous ma responsabilité est
ce que j'ai fait dans les deux heures
qui ont suivi c'est d'abord récupérer
leurs rapports écrits pour qu'il lui
écrive et pas seulement être dans le
dans l'oralité préparer la transmission
des données que je venais de recueillir
dans le cadre de lentilles 40 à monsieur
le procureur de la république
j'ai personnellement appelé françois
molins pour le lui dire et dans le même
temps que je saisisse et le procureur de
la république saisir le ministre de
l'intérieur le niveau central et j'ai eu
un échange au téléphone avec monsieur
gérard collomb lui-même pour lui
demander la suspension immédiate de ces
trois fonctionnaires et ça a été fait
dans la soirée les trois fonctionnaires
ont déposés ont déposé leurs armes vous
l'avez fait d'ailleurs mon voisin pour
pour un d'entre eux les deux autres
celles directeur de l'autre public il a
fait ça a été fait immédiatement et
c'était des fonctionnaires là sous mon
autorité et c'était à moi et à personne
d'autre de prendre cette initiative
voilà vraiment le choix qui a été le
mien et comme je les dis ailleurs c'est
un choix qui m'a conduit ce jour là et
le 2 mai et le 19 juillet si je puis
dire est que je vous expose la dans la
plus totale clarté et honnêteté et
choses sont très claires pour le 19
juillet mais permettez-moi de revenir
sur le 2
monsieur le préfet il y à la faute de
monsieur vénale à tout le monde en parle
il y a aussi les conditions de la faute
elles lui ont été offertes par nos
services
il y as sans doute la faute du cadre
dirigeant de la préfecture de police qui
en dehors de l'exercice de ses
compétences et de la délégation dont il
peut avoir bénéficié accorde la
possibilité à monsieur benalla d'être
accompagné par un autre fonctionnaire
pour assister aux opérations de maintien
de l'ordre que la sanction disciplinaire
infligée à monsieur benallal n'est plus
lui être infligée que par le directeur
de cabinet du président de la république
la cause est entendue
mais monsieur simoneau qui je crois est
celui que vous visiez quand vous parliez
de copinage malsain c'est comme ça que
nous le vont interpréter car il
s'agissait sans doute de sa relation
avec monsieur benalla que vous mettiez
en cause n'est pas lui même fait l'objet
de poursuites disciplinaires que
l'inspection générale de la police
nationale pour ce qui concernait
d'éventuels dysfonctionnements de
l'administration de la police n'ait pas
été saisie reste pour moi une question
du point de vue du bon fonctionnement de
l'état et je veux vous la poser oui et
je vais vous répondre
bien sûr j'ai eu l'occasion de dire
d'ailleurs mais je vous le redis ici
si la demande avait été soumise
ce qui n'a pas été le cas je ne l'aurais
pas refuser je voulais dit en
introduction une collaborateur du chef
de l'état autorisé par sa hiérarchie qui
souhaitent venir à la préfecture de
police je n'aurais pas dit non j'aurais
dit oui et sans aucun doute j'aurais
veiller à l'encadrement dans des
conditions autres
sans doute en mettant d'ailleurs auprès
de lui j'ai envie de dire on leur se
vend mieux d'ailleurs en mettant auprès
de lui un cadre de plus haut de plus
haut niveau mais sur le fait de
l'accueillir
je suis désolé en soi l'accueillir n'est
pas une faute
et si monsieur simon a commis une faute
c'est pas de l'accueillir
c'est de ne pas en rendre compte à sa
hiérarchie et de cela il lui a été fait
les reproches qui convenait sous forme
d'admonestation verbal par son directeur
c'est un défaut de rendre compte alors
s'étonne défaut de rendre compte en
temps donc c'est grave mais ce n'est
qu'un défaut de rendre compte
la faute c'est pas c'est pas d'avoir
accueilli c'est d'avoir organisé
l'accueil sans que son directeur a été
informé ni le préfet de police et un
défaut de rendre de rendre compte défaut
de loyauté hiérarchique est évidemment
moi j'ai demandé au directeur de l'ordre
public de faire à monsieur simonin sur
ce sujet les représentations sévère sous
forme d'admonestation qui convenait mais
on ne pouvait pas aller sur un terrain
disciplinaire haut de l'arbre
comme toujours la faute et la réponse de
la faute quelle est la faute c'est celle
là c'est pas le fait de lui avoir dit
oui venez c'est le fait d'avoir dit oui
venez sans que sa hiérarchie était est
et était prévenue voilà vraiment la
situation
vous parlez du contrôleur général simon
un permettez moi de dire un mot
j'ai été sans faiblesse vous le savez le
19 juillet mais là la grande faute là
qu'il a commis le 18 juillet au soir
avec deux autres collègues ça c'est une
grave faute que d'être allé chercher de
la vidéo pour l'amener à monsieur
benalla j'ai dit ma réaction tout à
l'heure mais cette grave faute n'enlève
à rien les mérites qu'il a eu par
ailleurs vous savez c'est un peu comme
un un grand footballeur il peut avoir
marqué trois buts lors d'un match
formidable mais si deux mois après il
commet quelque chose de dramatique
besset l'un et c'est l'autre
et si vous vous souvenez faut voir le
printemps qu'on a traversé les
interventions en milieu universitaire
évacuation de la sorbonne aucune
difficulté j'ai suivi ça en direct avec
les images aucune violence
aucun pépin aucune plainte évacuation de
tolbiac
on voulait pas me croire quand j'ai fait
un communiqué à 6h30 du matin pour dire
que tout s'était bien passé et que
c'était fini qui commandait les troupes
qui est allé c'était le contrôleur
général simonin donc c'est un
professionnel aguerri et je ne peux pas
effacer ses mérites
je les rappelle devant vous
tout en soulignant par ailleurs la
gravité à mes yeux de la faute qu'il a
commise et c'est là où j'ai évoqué le
copinage malsain et la formule a été
reprise pourquoi c'est à dire que une
peste de facilité dans ce copinage
malsain qui fait qu' on pense qu'on peut
comme ça en oubliant un petit peu les
des règles hiérarchiques et les
principes organiser d organiser des
choses mais le copinage malsain
on verra ce que dit la justice quand
elles auront connaître si elle vient sur
ce terrain là c'était pas non plus de
quoi de quoi aller au-delà de ce que
j'ai fait en sa direction c'est-à-dire
d'augmenter au directeur de l'ordre
public de lui faire les représentations
qui convenait et de le faire sous forme
d'admonestation verbale ça a été fait
merci monsieur le préfet monsieur le
rapporteur
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
préfet nous connaissons votre
professionnalisme celui de vos collègues
que vous avez évoquées esneu ne nous ne
méconnaissons pas la dureté de la tâche
vous avez cité et dans une journée comme
celle du premier mais c'est vrai que la
gestion de tout cela n'est pas du tout
facile
je me dois cependant de vous poser des
questions très précises
je vends posé trois pour éclairer la
commission et pour établir des faits
pour la première question porte sur le
port d'armes de monsieur benalla vous
avez indiqué devant la commission des
lois de l'assemblée nationale avoir
accordé un permis de port d'armes à
monsieur benalla en octobre 2017
alors je vous cite qu'il ne remplissait
pas les conditions réglementaires pour
disposer d'une arme
monsieur le directeur de cabinet du
président de la république a déclaré e
devant l'assemblée nationale qu'il avait
qu'il vous avait demandé lui même qu'il
y est un port d'armes attribuée à
monsieur benalla il vous l'avez demandé
mais en précisant je cite sous réserve
que cette autorisation puisse être
accordée dans le strict respect des
textes
or il est clair que cette autorisation
de port d'armes a été attribué dans des
conditions qui ne sont pas le strict
respect des textes
donc c'est ma première interrogation
monsieur le préfet je peux répondre
maintenant bien sûr c'est préfet s'il
vous plaît je réponds je réponds sur ce
point vous me faites dire un quelque
chose alors j'ai pas vu le verbatim qui
n'est pas en tout cas conforme à ce que
j'ai à ce que j'ai déclaré enfin je
verrai verbatim peut-être cette formule
ne s'y trouve mais je vais essayer là
aussi d'expliquer de quoi il s'agit on
est dans un cadre juridique assez
complexe qu'est celui du port d'armes
en fait vous avez deux régimes très
différents et aux finalités très
différentes et il ya sans doute parfois
des confusions
vous avez un premier régime juridique du
port d'armes qui relève de la compétence
du ministre de l'intérieur
la finalité je vais vous citer le
article r 300 15-5 est la suivante le
ministre de l'intérieur peut autoriser
par arrêter toute personne exposée à des
risques exceptionnels d'atteinte à sa
vie je dis bien des risques
exceptionnels de l'atteinte à sa vie sur
sa demande à apporter transporter une
arme de poing
la demande que monsieur benalla avait
formulées sur ce plan et dont d'ailleurs
je n'avais pas eu connaissance et
j'avais pas en avoir connaissance
puisqu'elle était du niveau ministériel
a été refusée a été refusé parce qu'il a
été apprécié à mon avis justement
apprécié que monsieur benalla n'était
pas une personne exposée à des risques
exceptionnels d'atteinte à sa vie super
nana a présenté ensuite à l'autorité
préfectorale que je suis une demande qui
sur un autre fondement l'autre fondement
je cite le texte de loi c les
fonctionnaires ou agents des
administrations publiques exposé par
leurs fonctions à des risques
d'agression et dans ce cadre-là l'elysée
au niveau de patrick strzoda a relayé la
demande
au regard des fonctions qu'exerçait
monsieur benalla à la présidence de la
république donc sonné sur un cadre
juridique qui n'a rien à voir avec le
port d'armes pour risques exceptionnels
d'atteinte à la vie on est sur un autre
cadre juridique et c'est dans ce cadre
juridique que j'ai donné l'autorisation
après l'instruction habituel en
recueillant le casier b2 et c
tous les éléments qui était nécessaire
pour donner cette autorisation
la petite nuance mais comme je les dis
je vais le redire là et que j'assume est
la suivante on renvoie ensuite à des
textes réglementaires qui disait un
arrêté ministériel qui définit les
services ou catégories de services
désignant ou accueillant les
fonctionnaires et agents le
la situation était particulière puisque
l'elysée ne figurait pas dans ces
catégories de services
mais compte tenu du fait que la demande
mme été relayé en disant bien que
c'était pour ses fonctions à l'elysée
oui j'ai accepté de le délivrer dans ce
cadre là mais j'insiste beaucoup sur la
différence parce que ça n'a rien à voir
donc j'ai pas substituer ma décision à
la précédente
je vais même vous dire et je citerai pas
des cas mais je connais certaines
situations et en tout cas oui j'en
connais où on a donné autorisation
en fait pour l'exercice de certaines
missions en se fondant sur le niveau
central des risques exceptionnels
d'atteinte à la vie alors que je ne
pense pas que ce soit ce soit le cas
donc là dessus qu'on soit bien clair on
était dans une compet une compétence
préfectoral donc que j'ai que j'ai
assumée normalement c'est mon devoir de
l'assumer et évidemment aussi lorsque la
mission monsieur benalla a cessé j'ai
immédiatement abrogé l'autorisation que
j'avais donnée elle était strictement
est uniquement liée à ses fonctions
ce qui veut dire aussi moi je sais pas
ce que l' enquête établira ce qui veut
dire aussi que s'il avait son arme
ce jour là lorsqu'il était place de la
contrescarpe il était en faute il
n'avait absolument pas à l'avoir vu ce
qu'il était hors des fonctions est un
jour de congé donc pour moi là dessus on
verra mois sur les images il ne semble
pas avoir vu mais c'est pas moi
d'apprécier
c'est le juge qui dira encore une fois
c'est une le cadre juridique c'est les
cetc
c'est le cadre juridique par exemple qui
s'applique pour les transporteurs de
fonds pour donner un exemple concret
liée à l'exercice des fonctions et
compte tenu des fonctions qui était à
l'elysée telles qu'elles ont été
rapportées
oui j'ai pressé j'ai pris cette décision
avec cette nuance ce que j'ai peut-être
évoqué au regard du cadre réglementaire
qu'il n'y avait pas dans l'arrêté
ministériel
la citation de l'elysée mais ce qui
n'est pas étonnant en revanche il y
avait l'affirmation de l'elysée mais je
confirme aussi que mon collègue denis
patrick strzoda me l'a transmis en dix
ans dans le respect des textes bien sûr
ces préfets 1
fonctionnaire de police un gendarme
naturellement porte une arme et peut-on
faire usage
mais il a un entraînement il a une
évaluation et il a une formation aux
conditions de l' usage de cette arme est
ce que ces trois conditions
vous avez veillé vous qui avez délivré
l'autorisation à ce qu'elle soit remplie
pour ce monsieur benalla oui elles ont
été remplis licence fédérale de tir
carnet de tir mentionnant les trois
tiers de contrôle annuel cartes etc tout
ce qui était lié à ce cadre juridique a
été vérifiée monsieur le président aux
règles de l'ue usage d'une arme pour
assurer la protection des jeunes à la
protection du président de la république
ça c'est la mission qui lui a été confié
oui c'est pas moi qui la lui est confiée
bien sûr mais le port d'armes n'est pas
seulement une affaire privée quand il
s'agit d'un collaborateur du président
qui occupe une fonction de garde du
corps
il est inquiétant pour le citoyen que je
suis et que nous sommes de savoir que à
la demande de la présidence de la
république on délivre un pope d'armes
certes avec quelqu'un qui est entraînée
vous l'avais dit à l'instant vous avez
vérifié cette condition et c'est heureux
mais les âges d'une arme pour protéger
le président et président de la
république ne peut pas être laissée à
l'improvisation at il reçu une formation
aux conditions dans lesquelles il peut
être admis à faire usage d'une arme
protéger une haute personnalité oui il
avait l'attestation formation continue
délivré par un major de police de la
cellule formation du gspr voilà et
toutes les autres conditions notamment
par rapport au casier b2 et c
elle était remplie elle était remplie
voilà ce qui m'a conduit à 7 à cette
décision toutes les conditions étaient
étaient remplies le l'enquète de de
moralité disait que rien ne se poser à
ce qu' il a été dit à l'extérieur oui
mais il ya eu en fait une affaire
judiciaire etc
mais il ya eu une décision du tribunal
qui l'a relaxé donc avait aucune mention
au à ce qu'on appelle
fichier tâches de traitement des
antécédents judiciaires donc les
conditions étaient celles de la était
celle là l'aspect l'aspect nuance je
voulais a indiqué je peux pas être plus
transparent mais sur le reste oui mais
c'est bon à porter je serai peut-être
plus court sur la deuxième question
parce qu'elle a déjà été largement
introduite par philippe bas notre
président finalement monsieur le préfet
le 2 mai c'est l'elysée qui a donné les
informations à la fois au ministre de
l'intérieur et au préfet de police de
paris
c'est à dire que les informations
viennent du de la présidence la
république et il peut apparaître
étonnant qu'il n'y ait aucune
information compte tenu de la gravité
des faits qui viennent de vos services
car enfin deux personnes sont là comme
observateurs elles sont sous l'autorité
de quelqu'un qui les contrôlent
il y à des policiers des crs qui sont là
et qui reste statique pour des raisons
de commandement qu'on nous a exposé il y
à d'autres policiers qui sont là seules
deux personnes interviennent dans le
moment précis en faisant usage de la
violence et de la force
je vais être prêt si monsieur présent de
la force qui en l'espèce peut être
légitime mais ces deux personnes ne sont
pas membres de la police nationale
il y a quelqu'un forcément sur place qui
est le commandant qui commande les spas
qui commande la police
comment peut-on imaginer que cette
personne devant la singularité de cet
acte des personnes qui ne sont pas
policiers qui font usage de la force
devant des policiers qui sont là que
cette personne ne fasse pas état de ce
qui s'est passé auprès de l'ensemble la
chaîne hiérarchique et dans le plus bref
délai au près
du préfet de police de paris donc il y à
là quelque chose qui peut apparaître
extrêmement singulier et choquant quelle
est votre analyse par rapport à cela
vous avez la parole donc la première
chose c'est que moi je n'ai eu aucun
compte rendu de ce type ça je peux je
peux l'affirmer je veux dire mais
s'était ensuite là que l'opération de
police sur la place de la contrescarpe
s'est déroulée a poursuivi ensuite plus
plus longtemps mais monsieur benalla n'y
était plus c'est encore une fois je
l'indiquais en découvrant les images ça
je crois que chacun l'a bien compris et
alerté par l'elysée que nous nous nous
voyons les choses
sur le fond les fonctionnaires de la
préfecture de police ya deux situations
différentes
le commissaire creusa il n'est pas là
parce qu'à monsieur benalla lui ne sais
pas du moins je n'ai aucune raison de
penser le contraire
si monsieur benalla est là ou ailleurs
c'est pas lui qui en était en charge lui
il était en charge d'une unité de crs je
crois que c'était la crs numéro 15 qui
avait d'abord travaillé sur le secteur
de la place valhubert au bas du
boulevard de l'hôpital et que nous avons
projeté dans le quartier latin puisque
nous savions qu'il y avait des volontés
après la manifestation elle-même sur son
parcours je le rappelle bastille place
d'italie d'aller dans le quartier latin
où on avait de l'agitation
on était intervenue la veille à la
faculté de censier parce qu'on pensait
qu'il pourrait y avoir des engins
explosifs étaient tellement commissaire
kroes à lui il se projette dans le
quartier latin pour gérer la situation
place de la contrescarpe avec des
militants qui s'étaient réunis sur la
place d'autres qui voulaient arriver par
les rues adjacentes avec la mission de
de l'âne empêcher ça c'est le rôle du
commissaire creusa après il ya le rôle
d'un fonctionnaire de police le major
mes skis qui avait été désigné par
comme monsieur simoneau pour être auprès
de monsieur de monsieur benalla et major
et sur place qu'aurait-il pu faire at il
rendu compte à sa hiérarchie immédiate
il l'a fait sans doute mais uniquement
un oral en tout cas moi je n'ai pas eu
de papiers mais si je reviens au début
de mon propos si je reviens au début de
mon propos si je reviens à l'exemple que
je donnais aussi sur le fait que ce
monsieur que nous aurons dimanche sur
l'étape finale du tour de france sera
auprès d'un contrôleur général à coup
sûr à coup sûr j'aurais placé auprès de
monsieur benalla un responsable
hiérarchique de notre niveau et à ce
moment là qu'est ce que ça change et ça
change la relation
ce major c'est un homme de 61 ans est il
donc c'est la fin de sa carrière et
c'est le grade sommitale c'est un homme
qui a été terriblement éprouvés par un
drame familial ya une dizaine d'années
qui finit sa reconstruction
moi je me mets à sa place là il faut pas
voir pénale monsieur benalla comme on le
voit aujourd'hui il faut voir monsieur
benalla avec laura qui était la sienne
le 1er mai et sa capacité réelle à lui
donner rester ici et cetera
voilà je la mesure je la mesure ainsi
comme on dit familièrement c'est la vie
vous savez moi je suis originaire d'un
milieu très simple et je connais ces
choses là je connais ces choses là on
n'est pas dans la théorie on est dans la
vie dans la vivrai avec les sentiments
avec les relations voilà ce qui s'est
passé est sans doute ai-je oran et je
rends hommage à ce majeur parce qu'il
est victime quelque part de cela parce
qu'il va être interrogé dans le cadre de
l' enquête judiciaire ce qui est normal
et il se trouve là parce qu'on lui dit
d'y aller comme le soldat de l'évangile
quelle est sa responsabilité
à mes yeux il n'a pas et je tiens à le
saluer surtout compte tenu de deux sons
de son parcours
c'est le préfet je tiens à dire moi
aussi les choses avec beaucoup de clarté
ici nacré mis non pas des personnes nous
ne sommes pas une sorte de tribunal bis
nous voulons la vérité des faits et je
suis particulièrement sensible à ce que
vous venez de dire
pour ce major et à l'explication que
vous donnez qui est inspiré d'une
connaissance des réalités humaines que
je partage je pense en effet que c'est
comme un accident d'avion je l' ai dit
plusieurs fois pendant ses auditions il
ya toute une chaîne de cran d'arrêt qui
n'ont pas fonctionné et que ce
fonctionnaire de police très respectable
dont vous avez décrit les difficultés
qu'il a rencontrées est une victime
en réalité de cette affaire et c'est
d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle en ce
qui nous concerne nous cherchons à
établir des dysfonctionnements qui sont
exactement ce que en creux vous décrivez
c'est à dire un collaborateur du
président de la république qui parce
qu'ils les collaborateurs du président
de la république avec un grand sentiment
d'impunité
détenteur d'une carte parée de bleu de
blanc et de rouge croit pouvoir prendre
la place des fonctionnaires de police ou
de gendarmerie qui assurent une
opération de maintien de l'ordre et
abuse de l'autorité qui l'exercent
naturellement et de fait auprès de
fonctionnaires de rang modeste en
s'imposant à eux et c'est ceci qui pour
nous est le plus intolérable du point de
vue non seulement de l'état de droit
mais du respect des valeurs de la
république et c'est ceux ci précisément
qui fonde la décision unanime
du sénat de donner à la commission des
lois les pouvoirs d'une commission d'
enquête pour comprendre comment dans
notre république qu'on en arrive à ce
genre de situation dans laquelle en
réalité tout le monde s'incline et il
n'y a pas de cran d'arrêt pour empêcher
ces excès de pouvoir voilà je lui dis
avec un peu de passion et beaucoup de
conviction
ce qui nous choque ici nous qui sommes
la représentation nationale
mais monsieur le président je partage je
partage votre sentiment
je partage moi j'ai découvert ça quand
je dis alors super étonnement on peut
choisir les mots mais enfin je partage
puis vous savez quand on a un parcours
comme le mien le respect de la loi le
respect du service de la république tout
le monde le connaît dans mon cas comme
le cas de l'immense majorité de mes
collègues
moi j'aime que les institutions
fonctionnent comme elles doivent
fonctionner ça va de soi mais encore une
fois le le choix et la présence c'est
pas moi qui l'ait qui l'imposé et c'est
un interlocuteur qui par ailleurs a eu
des qualités aussi moi je peux pas les
apprécier c'est pas mon collaborateur
mais comme toujours on n'est pas là pour
faire les justiciers
c'est tellement facile surtout quand
l'histoire est passée de la réécrire il
faut toujours regarder le pour le contre
le blanc le noir etc
et quand on a des choses à apprécier
toujours entendre les personnes aussi
mais ça la justice sera fera son oeuvre
mais à partir du moment où il ya une
donnée de fait pas seulement de fait mme
institutionnelle avec le mandat donné à
à ce monsieur mais je rappelle que ce
jour là de toute façon
de toute façon il n'était pas du tout
dans le cadre de ses missions
il était comme observateurs donc la
faute
la faute est une faute c'est la sienne
c'est un manquement individuel avec
toutes ses conséquences la faute elle
est là la faute elle est là c'est c'est
pas le fait d'être présent qui est une
faute le fait d'être accueillis à la
préfecture de police à l'occasion d'un
service d'ordre
ce n'est pas une faute le fait
d'accueillir un collaborateur du
président de la république ce n'est pas
une faute
la faute c'est le comportement de la
personne sur le terrain une fois qu'on a
dit ça après on peut parler du reste
monsieur le rapporteur
merci monsieur le préfet je vais poser
dessus tout simplement une troisième
question avant de donner le relais à
muriel jourda et à mes collègues mais je
me dois de vous poser cette troisième
question tout en partageant bien sûr
tout ce que vous dites sur le respect
des personnes
il se trouve que après cet axe cette
faute inadmissible de monsieur benalla
le directeur de cabinet du président de
la république décide de le mettre à pied
pendant quinze jours et le porte parole
de l'elysée dit et vous n'avez pas pu ne
pas l'entendre vous le savez il dit
qu'il sera au terme de ces quinze jours
de mise à pied démis de ses fonctions en
matière de sécurité et de protection
je cite donc ça me paraît très clair je
crois que devant un tel fait le bon sens
c'est d'exfiltrer le personnage et de
lui infliger une sanction briller une
sanction pour penser ce qu'on veut de 15
jours de mise à pied
mais là où il ya un problème que vous ne
pouvez pas ignorer c'est que après ses
quinze jours je pensais qu'ils seraient
chargés d'une tâche administrative
il se retrouve en première ligne à paris
au panthéon à 30 cm du président de la
république le 14 juillet dans la tribune
officielle à 30 cm du président de la
république lors de l'arrivée des bleus
dans l'autocar en expliquant qu'il faut
aller vite
même si les gens ont passé quatre heures
à attendre parce que c'est lui qui donne
des instructions
donc en tant que préfet de police
responsable de la police quel est à ce
moment là votre réaction
car vous ne pouvez pas ignorer qu'il
continue comme avant alors qu'il a été
démis de ses fonctions en matière de
sécurité ces préfets parti de là
de la question à laquelle je ne peux pas
répondre et qui doit être posée
autorités de l'elysée si vous permettez
moi ce que je peux dire là vous regardez
trois exemples que vous citez sur
l'organisation du panthéon et de la
cérémonie du panthéon pardon monsieur
patrick strzoda a bien expliqué les
choses hier il ya des missions du type
accueil des visiteurs bien mettre en
place les visiteurs dans les tribunes
qui n'ont pas grand chose à voir avec
des tâches de sécurité qui sont
parfaitement légitimes et qu'ils ne me
choque pas parce qu'elles sont
absolument nécessaires
ça c'est pas s'occuper de la sécurité
rapprochée du président de la république
c'est veiller au bon ordre de la
cérémonie à sa place en ce qui concerne
le 14 juillet c'est la même chose moi
j'ai entendu les déclarations de patrick
strzoda c'est à dire l'accueil des
invités du président de la république
sur la tribune qui leur est dédiée sur
la place de la concorde au bas des
champs-elysées c'est pas une mission de
sécurité
quant à l'épisode que j'ai vécu le plus
directement
c'est à dire le retour des bleus je ne
sais si monsieur benalla a donné des
ordres chauffeur de l'autobus puisque
moi j'étais pas de l'autobus mais je
peux vous dire que les ordres
fonctionnaire de police et le préfet de
police que je suis qui les a donnés et
personne d'autre
et quand je dis ça vous pouvez me croire
et quand on me connaît on peux me croire
merci monsieur préfet nous vous croyons
vous avez déposé sous serment
madame jourdain qui est notre autre
rapporteur merci monsieur le président
monsieur le préfet une question qui
rebondit si je puis dire sur les propos
que vous avez échangé avec monsieur le
président bah la vidéo des faits qui
sont déroulés le 1er mai a été remise en
quelque sorte a dit j'ai peine par un
internaute anonyme
on le sait sans que l'igpn ne connaisse
l'identité de l'auteur des faits cette
vidéo n'a pas donné de suite dans
l'immédiat nous a expliqué madame la
directrice de l'igpn
en revanche lorsque la question lui a
été posée de savoir quelle aurait été la
marche à suivre
si l'identité de l'auteur des faits
avait été connue c'est à dire si on
avait su qu'il s'agissait d'un
observateur elle a très clairement
répondu qu'il aurait fallu mettre en
oeuvre une enquête administrative et une
enquête judiciaire
cette perception a été confirmée quoique
en des termes différents par monsieur
normand directeur général de la police
nationale qui a lui-même indiqué que
l'illégitimité de l'intervention aurait
justifié aussi qu'une enquête soit mise
en oeuvre explique en lui-même qu'il en
avait eu connaissance que le 18 juillet
vous même avez eu connaissance de
l'identité de l'intervenant monsieur
benalla le premier jour le 2 mai
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur on a
eu connaissance le cabinet de monsieur
le ministre l'intérieur en a eu
connaissance
pour autant aucun devant n'a songé à
mettre en oeuvre ou faire mettre en
oeuvre l'enquète administratives ou
l'enquète judiciaire est-ce que l'aura
de monsieur benalla dont nous parlions
tout à l'heure qui a pu impressionner
les majors misère ce qui est qu'il y au
fait qu'il appartienne au cabinet de
l'élysée a pu influencer votre décision
de ne pas mettre en oeuvre une enquête
administrative ou une enquête judiciaire
monsieur le préfet je réponds volontiers
ce n'est pas son aura c'est son
positionnement et son autorité
hiérarchique j'ai répondu à la première
question on confirme sur la vidéo que
que c'est monsieur benalla monsieur
benalla est un collaborateur de l'elysée
qui m'a alerté sur la situation dans
lequel je suis vous l'avez compris et
c'est cette instance hiérarchique qui
prend le dossier en main voilà la vérité
est celle là rien de plus rien de moins
donc c'est pas pour moi un problème doha
ne croyez surtout pas cela c'est
simplement le positionnement et
hiérarchique c'est un collaborateur du
de l'elysée c'est la hiérarchie de
l'elysée qui prend le dossier en compte
voilà comment ça c'est passé tout à
l'heure votre président monsieur le
président vous a demandé est ce qu'il y
avait eu des échanges et c'est une
décision expresse décision tacite je
prie le bo décision tacite parce que
juridiquement c'est comme ça qu'on peut
la l'a qualifiée mais sans qu'il y ait
eu deux dents de concert tu mets pas du
tout c'était évident en tout cas pour
moi je les dis dans notre cadre que le
responsable hiérarchique devait prendre
en main le dossier et les suites à
donner à la faute ce qui a été fait
alors on peut à prédire
sap a été fait avec assez de rigueur
avec à cette force et c'est moi il
m'appartient pas de me prononcer je suis
préfets les décisions qui sont prises à
ce niveau là je les je les respecte je
niche de l'est commente ni les impôts ni
les réprouve
c'est mon devoir c'est mon métier si je
faisais autrement je serais pas conforme
à ma mission
mais la réaction eu lieu il ya eu une
sanction après vous pouvez dire elle
n'était pas la bonne
il fallait plus c'est votre droit le
plus strict mais c'est pas sur ce
terrain là que le préfet de police
pouvaient se placer il s'est placé sur
le terrain institutionnel qui est
évidemment naturellement le mien donc
nous commençons par monsieur collombat
vous avez dit que la responsabilité
hiérarchique devait suivre le ctl de
suivre le dossier de contrôle et les
sanctions enfin et c'est très bien mais
quand même
l'organisation de vos services c'est
vous or le 1er mai vous découvrez donc
monsieur benalla dans la salle de
commandement vous en étonnez vous l'avez
dit bon le lendemain aux apprenait par
l'elysée qu'une vidéo circule c'est pas
tellement le problème de la vidéo pour
nous c'est ce qui est dans la vidéo mais
de quoi elles témoignent elle témoigne
que quelqu'un simplement parce que il a
une carte de visite
il peut aller jouer les cow boys dans
des opérations qui sont des opérations
votre responsabilité donc ma question
c'est la suivante qu'est ce que vous
envisagez pour essayer de faire en sorte
que l'existant que ces décisions tacite
que ce type de confusion ne soit plus
d'un pas de soi ne puisse plus se
reproduire
parce que c'est cette confusion déjà
nous qui nous qui nous intrigue plus il
est évidemment le président a raison
c'est pas d'incriminer tel lampistes ou
soul en piste c'est pas ça le problème
mais c'est effectivement l'angle
institutionnels comme vous le même vous
l'avez dit c'est préfet je reviens un
peu sur les faits et puis après recontré
volontiers à votre question et votre
orientation là aussi que je que je
partage sur l'épisode du 1er mai au soir
je me permets simplement de rappeler le
contexte mois j'accueille monsieur le
ministre d'état dans un premier temps il
vient à mon bureau je peux lui faire un
peu un point de situation donnée les
premiers éléments de remonter mais à
cette heure-là on est un peu avant 20
heures le la journée loin d'être finie
je rappelle qu'on a eu les
interpellations jusqu'à 23h 200 environ
280 il ya deux chiffres qui circulent
276 283 importe près de 280
interpellation 153 présentation au pgi
109 garde à vue c'est pas souvent
connaît ça donc on est encore dans le
show de l'action est cantonné à la salle
de commandement de la préfecture de
police dont ont fait le le tour le
ministre est là pour venir saluer les
fonctionnaires les remercier je suis
évidemment à ses côtés effectivement
avec étonnement je vois dans un angle
monsieur benalla sans savoir qu'ils
étaient là de la journée puisque
personne n'avait parlé et vous savez la
conversation était très furtive parce
qu'on faisait le tour on serre la main
vous êtes la vacuité sur le terrain bon
et on passe à autre chose et le autre
chose ça a été de finir de gérer mais
d'abord pour moi évidemment la visite du
ministre de le raccompagner à peine
s'était finie c'était le cabinet du
premier ministre qui m'a sollicité pour
organiser son déplacement
monsieur le premier ministre est venu à
l'hôtel de police du xiiie
arrondissement gelé accueilli le jeu
veiller aussi
cueillir en même temps le miz des tamis
l'intérieur voilà sur la pour la soirée
du 1er mai la soirée du 2 mai et là je
me suis couché un peu tard après j'ai
pas c'était pas fini encore le 2 mai au
matin j'étais convié sur deux médias
nationaux
donc j'étais à 7h50 à france inter j'ai
enchaîné à 8h20 sur bfm
je suis allé au ministère de l'intérieur
où il y avait une réunion d'états majors
j'ai dû y arriver vers 9h partir
peut-être vers 9h45
comme je l'aï indiqué c'est pendant ce
trajet que je suis d'abord alerté sur le
fait qu'ils auraient une vidéo sur des
violences policières
et c'est après quand je suis à mon
bureau vers 10h15 que je sais que c'est
la sphère vénale art comme me l'a appris
d'elysée et à ce moment là j'ai mis en
oeuvre les réactions que vous dites mais
dans les réactions que je vous dit
j'insiste sur les réactions internes
c'est à dire immédiatement demandé au
directeur de l'ordre public pourquoi
comment et c'est là où lui découvre que
l'autorisation avait été donnée à un
niveau qui n'était pas pertinent donc
qui fait les représentations mais sur la
base sur la base du du du manquement à
la loyauté à la loyauté hiérarchie après
mais comme je vous le mets je l' ai déjà
expliqué le fait je redis si vous voulez
le fait d'accueillir une personnalité à
la préfecture de police
c'est pas c'est pas en soi un problème
je vous ai dit que le principe stay
d'accueillir le problème est que ça a
été mis en place à un niveau non
pertinents mais je le dis je le redis
puisque le directeur n'était pas
informée mais c'est possible parce qu'à
une initiative entre copains comme je
les dis donc vous savez ce que c'est les
copains monsieur le sénateur a belle
initiative entre copains j'ai envie de
dire c'est la vie c'est ce que j'ai dit
on sait quand je dénonce ed j'ai dénoncé
des dérives individuelles sur fond de
copinage malsain c'est ça si vous voulez
inversement comprenez bien aussi que la
proximité qui existe entre les équipes
de l'elysée notamment les équipes qui
assure la sécurité rapprochée du
président de la république et les
équipes de la préfecture de police
elle est indispensable il y as besoin
donc
un climat de proximité et de confiance
pourquoi sur le territoire de paris et
de la petite couronne toute la sécurité
du président de la république elle est
sous ma responsabilité
nous assurons toutes ces escortes y
compris jusqu'à jusqu'à villacoublay
c'est les équipes de la démo pc donc ce
lien de travail qui existait entre
monsieur benalla et les équipes de
l'année au pc il est pas scandaleux en
soi ce qui ce qui a dérapé c'est la
manière dont on devient as tu as toi je
vais présenter les choses comme ça mais
c'est pas moi qu'il faut en faire le
reproche c'est bien aux intéressés c'est
bien de ça dont il faut s'expliquer mais
la conséquence est celle que l'ona je
vais je vais ajouter un petit mot si
vous le permettez
il ya un point et gelé peut être évoqué
trop vite en introduction
je vous ai dit à quel point l'accueil
des scolaires des universitaires étaient
bien encadrés par des conventions
je vous ai dit aussi qu'on a mis en
place des systèmes de convention pour la
presse pour les journalistes lorsqu'ils
sont en immersion je parle pas quand on
leur travail
je suis convaincu je suis convaincu
qu'il faut qu'on fasse un effort pour
mieux formalisés l'accueil des
observateurs extérieurs mais sans
l'alourdir alex et moi je vais pas
demander comme préfet de police que me
viennent toutes les décisions et on va
faire un effort mais oui mais ça
ce qu'on voudra ça changera rien du tout
même
écoutez cfc votre c'est votre conclusion
moi je vous dis pas ne dit pas autre
chose mais c'est pas mon collaborateur
c'est pas moi qui les désignent c'est
pas le préfet de police ce qui a fait le
choix donc poser les questions qui vous
devez les posez moi je peux répondre
dans le genre de ma compétence dans le
champ de mes responsabilités d'ailleurs
je ne sais pas si monsieur le préfet
j'entends cette réponse mais monsieur
leroi s'il vous plaît oui monsieur le
président - vous avez posé des questions
avec les rapporteurs enfin mes questions
mais je voudrais juste dire à monsieur
le préfet que c'est vrai que le
positionnement de cette personne a
neutralisé toute la chaîne d'aidé des
autorités constituées qui aurait pu
malgré tout effectivement enclenché
l'article 40 puisque vous même vous
constatez le 2 qu' ils portent un
brassard de policiers que c'est une
infraction caractérisée et rien n'aurait
pu effectivement vous empochez le peu de
empêché de porter à la connaissance du
procureur de la république ce que vous
avez constaté le procureur et un juge de
l'opportunité des poursuites
mais je comprends que ce positionnement
neutraliser tout le monde c'est ça qui
est grave quand j'ai parlé de
rattachement hiérarchique
oui oui vous dites positionnement moi
j'ai parlé de rattachement niant tout à
fait monsieur kenner ce préfet de police
une écoute une enquête n'empêche pas la
convivialité dont je voulais vous
adresser toutes mes félicitations pour
votre promotion au grade de commandeur
de la légion d'honneur
voilà le 14 juillet dernier c'est
important et cela c'est la
reconnaissance d'un grand commis de
l'état que j'ai eu le plaisir de
pratiquer en tant que ministre pendant
quelques années
je préfère plus directement vous avez
été nommé le 19 avril 2010 est donc vous
avez entre guillemets pratiquer
régulièrement monsieur benalla dans vos
différentes rencontres en tout cas vous
saviez qu'il n'était pas policier vous
savez qui n'est pas policier votre place
si hier soir le votre patron entre
guillemets gérard collomb ministre
d'état de l'intérieur en l'occurrence
nous a dit j'ai toujours pensé que
monsieur ban a été policier y compris
dans le cadre des meetings électoraux du
président de la république je voulais un
peu avoir votre sentiment sur le sujet
et sur le fait qu' il y ait pu y avoir
un doute sur la non qualification de ce
jeune homme de 26 ans même s'il est nous
l'avons appris plus tard
lieutenant-colonel de réserve de la
gendarmerie
première question deuxième question la
vidéo reçue par l'igpn le 2 mai sur la
plate forme de signalement est elle la
même que celle que vous avez jamais
visionné à l'occasion donc de votre
échange avec l'elysée la deuxième
question je réponds très vite je ne sais
pas je suis le ministre a donc je ne
sais pas à la première je veux dire les
choses telles que je les ai vécus
monsieur benalla je les rencontrais la
première fois lors d'une réunion que
j'ai présidé personnellement et qui
devait être le vendredi avant le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle donc monsieur ben y avait
monsieur benalla il y avait monsieur
jean marie cherrier que lui je
connaissais déjà puisque je l'avais
rencontré à lyon est peut-être une ou
deux autres personnes non souvenirs et
pas suffisamment précis mais il me
semble qu'ils étaient quatre pourquoi
cette réunion c'était mon devoir
il s'agissait de veiller à la sécurité
de la soirée du deuxième tour dont il y
avait de bonnes raisons de penser que le
candidat emmanuel macron sortirait
vainqueur donc moi j'ai rencontré
monsieur benalla ensuite je vous dis
d'ailleurs que monsieur girier passer un
petit moment dans mon bureau
tout simplement parce qu'on se
connaissait déjà pour échanger un peu
mais
monsieur benalla ne s'est jamais
présentée comme policier moi je n'ai
jamais pensé que monsieur benalla été
était policier au demeurant mes services
mais ça mange ans n'avait pas
connaissance ou rappelé effectivement
j'ai pris mes fonctions le 19 en fait je
les ai pris le 18 au soir je le rappelle
au moment de l'assassinât de xavier de
sa vieille juge les mais puisque mon
service avait eu à gérer une
autorisation de port d'armes qui lui
avait été délivrée de détention d'armes
pour la sécurité des locaux du siège
dans marche autorisation qui était caduc
que je crois la plus tardive au 20 juin
2010 est donc mes services connaissaient
très bien la situation monsieur benalla
ensuite moi je ne les ai pas vu très
souvent monsieur benalla je l' ai vu à
l'occasion de déplacements du président
de la république sur le territoire
parisien
peut-être la cérémonie du 11 novembre
dans ces situations là le la journée où
j'ai été pas très loin de lui le plus
longtemps c'est la visite que monsieur
le président de la république a fait au
salon de l'agriculture où contenu la
sensibilité de la journée
j'ai été sur place toute la journée
personnellement un pour veiller au
meilleur déroulement des choses et
monsieur benalla était aux côtés du
président de la république dans le rôle
qui était qui était le sien mais ni plus
ni moins mais pour moi c'était un
collaborateur acquis démission avait été
confié y compris par le biais de la
sollicitation qui est venue jusqu'à moi
laquelle j'ai répondu favorablement pour
le pour le port d'armes puisqu'elle
était clairement dans le cadre de ses
missions
voilà ensuite je peux vous assurer par
exemple n'est pas effacé que j'ai jamais
eue le méro téléphone portable de
monsieur benalla en revanche il était un
interlocuteur régulier de mes équipes
comme je l'indiquais quand il ya des
déplacements du président de la
république sur paris il ya des réunions
qui se tiennent à l'elysée il ya des
visites de terrain qui s'y trouvent
s'ils trouvent les collaborateurs de la
des opc souvent au niveau contrôleur
général et un de mes collaborateurs du
cabinet souvent monsieur jérôme mazars
yole qui est à mes côtés mais c'est sauf
cas exceptionnel jamais le préfet de
police lui même qui s'y trouvent
vous vous en doutez bien non content il
ya des collaborateurs qui le voyait très
régulièrement autant ce n'est pas le cas
du
du préfet de police tout simplement
c'était le positionnement on va dire
pierrard chic qui n'en faisaient pas un
interlocuteur mon interlocuteur oui et
puis ça je le savais et puis
l'interlocuteur pour moi les visées
c'est le directeur du cabinet son
adjoint mais personne d'autre enfin sauf
exception prochaine intervenante madame
delattre merci une minute de madame
delattre oui monsieur le préfet vous
connaissez monsieur benalla puisque vous
l'a interpellé de façon sèche dans la
salle de commandement vous le connaissez
vous préfet de paris
alors on peut s'en étonner mais on
comprend de mieux en mieux au fil des
auditions parce qu'il est à des réunions
à des niveaux il ne devrait pas être
alors qu'il a un niveau il ne devrait
pas être dans ces réunions
apparemment donc ma question est simple
est-ce que vous avez alertés avant le
1er mai le ministre de l'intérieur ou
votre collègue ami monsieur strzoda
comme vous le précisez de la place
déplacer que prenez monsieur benalla
puisque on la prend au fil des auditions
il dérangeait votre personnel il l'a
même humilié des policiers lors de
déplacements présidentiels notamment
donc oui ma question est qui dans cette
république par le droit mais aussi par
l' usage peut prévenir ce type de dérive
et en l'occurrence est ce que vous
préfet de police
n'avez vous pas un rôle à jouer dans ce
type de prévenance de dérive le préfet
vous évoquez des réunions avec monsieur
benhadda il y en a une c'est celle dont
je vous ai relaté la teneur tout à
l'heure la veille ou l'avant veille du
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle et je vous ai dit madame
la sénatrice qu'ensuite les contacts
sont à notre niveau et un niveau de
qualité
non
surtout pas dire le contraire donc et
monsieur benalla moi je vous indiquais
que je le rencontrais lorsque le
président était sur le terrain et que je
me trouvais et le préfet de police est
pas tous les déplacements du président
de la république au sein de la capitale
et de sa zone de compétence vous vous en
doutez bien
donc ensuite comme je les dis me
semble-t-il au à l'assemblée nationale
je travaille mes équipes travaillent
avec les interlocuteurs qu'on leur donne
c'est pas moi qui définit la composition
de la réunion moi je ne dis jamais à
l'elysée ou autre ou ici au sénat je
viens en réunion voilà je veux monsieur
et madame untel ça se passe pas comme ça
ça c'est l'elysée qui désigne les
collaborateurs qui vont réunion
ce n'est pas moi mais je vais ajouter
une chose moi je n'ai eu comme préfet de
police aucune remontée de la part de mes
services je dis bien aucune sur une
situation au cours de laquelle monsieur
benalla aurait par son comportement
perturbé ou mis en péril ou gêner le
fonctionnement de de notre institution
je n'ai eu aucune remontée
j'entends ça ces jours ci mais je peux
vous affirmer qu'il n'y en a eu aucune
s'il y en avait une j'aurais sans doute
connaissant mon tempérament
effectivement alerté le directeur de
cabinet en disant que patrick peut-être
fait attention minyana eu aucune
et je vais pas raconter des histoires
après coup pour essayer de d'embellir la
réalité merci monsieur le préfet madame
lherbier monsieur le préfet de police
quand on parle de videolan et les
fonctionnaires qui ont donné la vidéo
les vidéos à monsieur benalla était ce
des copies des originaux et ton sûr
d'avoir tout récupérer les vidéos
auquel cas si ça n'était pas le cas on
pourrait avoir d'autres fait ça comme
vous le savez madame la sénatrice il ya
une enquête judiciaire
et encore une fois je vous ai dit à quel
point ma réaction a été mais elle est
évidente a et celle du directeur de
l'ordre public
c'est pas moi qui vous ennuie demandé
très vite de de saisir l'autorité
judiciaire sur ce sur ce fait donc
l'autorité judiciaire va travailler moi
le contenu des vidéos qui a été remis à
monsieur benalla je ne peux pas le
connaître par par construction je sais
qu'il ya un sujet qui va être traitée
mais sans doute derrière y aura-t-il y
aura-t-il une réflexion le le délai de
conservation des images tirées de
vidéoprotection ces 30 jours donc là on
était au delà des des 30 jours et il va
falloir savoir et comprendre pourquoi
si on fait des photographies sur une
manifestation à ma connaissance ya
aucune règle dans la durée de
conservation
si on fait avec nos caméras à l'épaule
les des films
à ma connaissance il n'y a aucune règle
sur la durée de conservation ou a
fortiori ce que chacun d'entre nous peut
faire sur cet outil
donc moi je suis veillent au respect des
règles j'avais déjà depuis ma prise de
fonction à plusieurs reprises et
notamment le 4 juin de cette année
encore renouvelé à mes services les
consignes du strict respect du du cadre
de droit
j'ai limité l'accès aux images par
exemple la situation que j'avais
découverte à l'occasion d'un drame c'est
que de n'importe quel poste de salles de
commandement de la préfecture de police
tahir y compris la petite couronne on
pouvait accès à toutes les images de
notre système vidéo et c'est sans doute
comme ça qu'à notre grand dam
l'agression contre un de nos
fonctionnaires sur le parvis de notre
dame c'est un coup de marteau souvenez
vous au mois de juin 2017 s'étaient
retrouvés
deux heures après sur les écrans de
télévision j'ai saisi l'igpn bien
entendu j'ai saisi l'igpn est depuis
lors j'ai verrouillé pour que ne puisse
avoir accès aux images territorialement
que ceux du territoire concerné sa gelée
mis en place le 4 juin j'ai rappelé les
règles
donc je verrai évidemment j'accueillerai
avec beaucoup d'intérêt ce qui sort de
l'anc est à la fois au plan judiciaire
et au plan administratif par rapport à
ce sujet mais il ya des questions qui
seront qui seront à apposer regarde ça
on en tirerait toutes les conséquences
sans aucune difficulté ça va de soi
madame de la gontrie
merci président monsieur le préfet
chacun depuis début de nos auditions
fait une lecture de l'article 40 qui est
erroné en restreignant à aux personnes
placées sous l'autorité hiérarchique
ce qui n'est pas le cas puisque la seule
condition c'est que vous ayez eu
connaissance des faits dans l'exercice
de vos fonctions ses génériques c'est à
dire chacun de ceux qui auraient pu être
amené à ça devait être dans l'exercice
de vos fonctions nulle part il n'est
précisé que ça doit être concernant des
inférieurs hiérarchique
deuxième point vous êtes vous entretenu
avec votre collègue dgpn avec le
ministre ou avec votre collègue
directeur de cabinet du président de la
république entre le 2 mai le 18 juillet
de fait donc vous au moins vous ne
contestez pas avoir eu connaissance
c'est à dire les faits concernant
monsieur benalla puisque je l'indiquais
le ministre comme le dgpn ont dit
l'avoir découvert à la lecture du monde
troisième point avez-vous depuis lors
demandez à vos services de regarder si
des faits analogues de participation
illégitime à des manifestations dans des
fonctions qui n'était pas la sienne
pouvait être reproché à monsieur benalla
je vous remercie madame près de l'est
madame la vice présidente catherine
troendlé président merci monsieur le
préfet tout le monde s'accorde est à
dire que finalement la protection du
président de la république relève des
fonctionnaires de police et
des militaires ma question porte sur la
demande d'autorisation de prise de faim
de port d'armes de monsieur benalla est
ce que vous aviez connaissance dans
précédent
dans le même contexte un collaborateur
qui demande au préfet de police
une autorisation de port d'armes si la
réponse est non monsieur le préfet je
pense que la cnam la démarche vous
sembler sans doute un peu incongru est
ce que vous auriez dû en informer le
ministre de l'intérieur est ce que cela
aurait peut-être constituer une première
alerte par rapport à un comportement peu
transgressives madame cost merci
monsieur le président monsieur le préfet
ma question a déjà été vous avez répondu
à ma question le concerné les graves
dérives comportementales qui nous ont
été signalés hier à propos de monsieur
benalla donc qui veut effectivement le
mot terreur a été employée et ça a été
répétée par plusieurs syndicats dont je
voulais savoir si évidemment vos
directeurs même vous même aviez eu vent
de ces dérives comportementales et est
ce que ces derniers jours vous avez vous
même sollicité de l'information cet
égard puisque vous commencez à en parler
et je crois que ce serait utile de le
vérifier
alors maintenant aussi menaçants
[Musique]
il a aucune formation particulière
ensemble de choses aucune expérience
professionnelle si ce n'est d'avoir géré
des la sécurité dans des boîtes de nuit
ou dans un certain nombre d'autres
circonstances
et vous avez parlé de de copinage
malsain en visant si bien que le
comprendre certains nouveaux
fonctionnaires mais je crois que les
copinage malsain c'est peut-être pas au
niveau de fonctionnaires qu'il faut les
trouver
c'est au niveau de ceux qui ont nommé
quelqu'un qui a absolument pas les
compétences pour être le tenant colonel
à des fonctions à un âge et à des
fonctions ou bien souvent seulement les
gens qui ont vocation d'être clos tenant
colonel à 40 ou 50 ans après avoir fait
saint cyr ou des grandes écoles arrive
finalement à faire valoir leur espace
professionnel donc ce monsieur
manifestement il doit avoir des réseaux
d'influencé
il doit avoir 10 ont une un poids énorme
et je suis quand même un peu surpris
qu'un finalement très souvent dix ans
dans cette affaire là on reporte
directement ou indirectement certaines
responsabilités sur des fonctionnels bon
coton il faut taire quand on a été
fonctionnaire on sait très bien que s'il
ya un gars qui déboule qui arrivent en
disant il faut faire cinq ans sans doute
en roulant un peu les mécaniques et en
expliquant que c'est lui le meilleur que
c'est le bras droit du président comment
peut-on reprocher ou envisageaient de
reprocher à des fonctionnaires comme on
le fait actuellement de dison d'avoir
obtempéré
et de s'être en gros laisser faire alors
ma question si la suivante monsieur le
préfet la directrice de chers collègues
nous avons prévu une minute pour chaque
question juste devant les jets pas posée
depuis ce matin juste je remercie d'être
là d'ailleurs fils de l'igpn nous a dit
que les violences étaient eux qui sont
le point de départ de l'opération était
très très légère que c'était disons il
n'y a pas eu de blessé il ya rien eu et
ma question est la suivante est ce que
ce qu'on reproche tout ce qu'on fait à
l'encontre des fonctionnaires auraient
été faits s'il n'y avait pas eu le
contexte politique s'il n'y avait pas eu
monsieur benalla benalla qui qui par ses
exactions son comportement et ses avait
enclenché une affaire qui devient une
affaire d'état
et moi ce qui m'inquiète c'est qu'on est
on va avoir des fonctionnaires moi je le
sens très fort on va voir des
fonctionnaires c'est finalement on y
sont quasiment pour rien qu'ils vont
tous prendre dans la figure
alors la question ma question c'est est
ce qu'on n'est pas en train directement
ou indirectement de cibler les lampistes
parce que les vrais responsables c'est
ce qu'ils ont nommé monsieur pénale
je remercie une dernière question de
madame arribes et puis je donne la
parole à monsieur le préfet alors la
question était partiellement imposé par
jean yves le conte madame cost et
vous-même président bah moi je trouve
qu'entre les langues se délient
nous avons été terrorisés et je n'ai
rien eu comme remontée de mes services
il ya un fossé énorme qui pose question
sur l'organisation à l'intérieur et sur
la capacité des changes
dans vos services voici le préfet bien
je vais essayer de couvrir un peu le
champ des le champ des questions
s'étonner qu'on reporte des
responsabilités sur des fonctionnaires
moi je suis là pour les protéger je
m'étonne comme vous et j'ai évoqué tout
à l'heure le cas du major qui était qui
était sur place dans les termes que vous
avez que vous avez entendu il me semble
que ce que j'ai pu entendre hier soir
répond à ce souci que que vous exprimer
et je crois que pour les fonctionnaires
c'est des moments un peu difficiles
parce qu'ils ont le sentiment d'être
être mise en cause dans un contexte où
leur part réelle de responsabilité
d'initiative et sûrement pas en tout cas
pour grande majorité d'entre eux ont
cause donc je ne peux qu'aller dans le
sens que vous avez que vous avez
indiquée quand j'ai évoqué copinage
malsain qu'on comprenne bien
effectivement c'est cette proximité à la
fois nécessaire est absolument
indispensable mais qui dérive et je les
qualifier comme tels ça a été repris y
compris je crois par monsieur le premier
ministre la tribune de l'assemblée
nationale hier donc je ne retire oria
mais sa vis bien cet aspect que je
connais sur les remontées la question
des déclarations des syndicats ou au
tout ça et des syndicats de police je
les vois évidemment très souvent et mes
collaborateurs les voit très souvent
aussi que ce soit le préfet secrétaire
général pour l'administration de la
durée du directeur régional l'inspecteur
général foucault dont c'est un petit peu
le le champ d'activité je vous affirme
que jamais rien nous a été indiqué je
verrai bien ce qu'ils dénoncent qui nous
donnent des faits moi je les prendrai en
compte
je les prendrai en compte au delà des
des pétitions principe quand où comment
dans quelles circonstances qu'on vient
de me le dire et je regarderai ce qui
est
ce qui est derrière sur la question du
du port d'armes y avait-il un précédent
à ma connaissance non mais encore une
fois moi j'ai un élément dossier mes
services ont nous avons obtenu de
l'elysée
un document qui cadre bien la réalité de
la mission confiée à monsieur b dallas
et c'est sur la base de ce document
encore une fois sans pression je les dis
et je confirme ce qu'a dit complètement
patrick strzoda que la décision a été
prise
première alerte il ya eu d'autres
décisions moi j'ai appris mais j'ai
appris peut-être ces jours-ci là qu'il y
avait une habilitation qui avaient été
donnés secret défense elle est bien
antérieure à c'est à ces événements moi
j'ai aucune aucune idée sur le sujet
mais c'est pour pour le signaler la
question de l'article 40 je l'évoqué
c'était un article dont nous connaissons
les dispositions qui est très large en
effet qui ne précise pas à qui dois à
tel ou tel moment nous le savons tous
je crois avoir répondu je vous ai dit
qu'elle était la latitude qui était qui
était la mienne à partir du moment où le
dossier était pris en compte le
directeur du cabinet du président de la
république a indiqué que son
appréciation ne l'avait pas conduit à
considérer qu'il y avait matière à
ensuite chacun peut porter un jugement
sur cette appréciation mais comme
toujours
l'appréciation de l'autorité compétente
7 qui convient et au demeurant
l'éclairage qu'a donnée l'igpn va plutôt
dans ce sens vous avez indiqué vous est
fait référence à la lecture du monde
mais là j'ai pas compris ce que parce
qu'après vont me faire lecture du monde
elle est récente elle et du 18 juillet
mais
je pardonne et moi parce que je vous ai
demandé si vous étiez entretenu avec le
ministre
le dgpn ou le directeur de cabinet entre
le 2 mai et le 18 juillet puisque le
ministre comme le jeans indique avoir
connu à la lecture du monde
les opérations concernées de gpn ça a
été évoqué peut-être lors de réunions
informelles je ne sais pas mais moi j'en
réfère aux ministres je suis une
autorité préfectorale
je rappelle que le préfet de police est
une autorité territoriales déconcentrées
c'est pas un directeur un troisième
directeur général avec le avec le nom se
voit pas tous les jours non madame le
préfet ne vous laissez pas la bdc j'ose
dire quoi poursuivre et le déroulement
de vos réponses et 18 juillet belle
nous en avons parlé de manière
informelle mais moi mes interlocuteurs
sur ce sujet c'est et qui le cabinet du
ministre et le cabinet de l'elysée dans
les jours qui ont suivi oui ensuite est
ce qu on en a reparlé
je dois à l'honnêteté de vous dire non
comme ça votre pense réponse à votre
question trouve trouver réponse les
faits analogues gelée indique et moi je
aucun n'a été porté à ma connaissance je
l' ai dit plusieurs fois devant vous je
le confirme dans siliana quelle que soit
la source qu'on vienne me les qu'on
vienne me les exposer premières
questions qui m'ont été posées dans
cette dernière tournée si je puis dire
le gspr ne relève absolument pas de ma
compétence et de mon autorité
donc je n'ai aucune idée sur la manière
dont ça se passe en interne et je n'ai
aucune qualité pour me prononcer là
dessus et j'ai indiqué la les relations
de travail normal car entre les équipes
de la préfecture de police et les
équipes de l'elysée
entre ton comme l'on veut
à la préfecture de police si on est
préfet de police il faut y être nommé
par décret en conseil des ministres et
puis pour toutes les autres personnes
bien évidemment il ya des cartes d'accès
qui sont délivrés on entre à la
préfecture de police en étant contrôlés
et habilité cela va de soi pour revenir
peut-être à votre question donc le
premier mais comment monsieur benalla
est venu à la la salle de commandement
je rappelle encore une fois qu'ils
avaient été accueillies certain niveau
pertinent pertinents mais il a été
accueilli
je ne vais pas dire autre chose un major
était auprès de lui qui lui est habilité
et qu'il a dans le cadre de cet accueil
ainsi organisées sans aucun doute guider
jusqu'à la salle de commandement voilà
comment les choses ont pu se passer
j'espère avoir répondu à vos questions à
celle ci aux autres monsieur le
président merci monsieur le préfet cette
audition est donc terminée merci d'avoir
coopéré avec notre commission des lois
[Musique]